Bei sonnigen 33 °C präsentierte sich das Bundesheer,
genauer gesagt das Kommando Schnelle Einsätze, am Freitag Nachmittag in Rossatz.
Das die Vorführungen an der kühlen Donau stattfanden,
war unter den Besuchern mehr als willkommen.
Die eindrucksvolle Leistungsschau des Bundesheeres war auf mehrere Stationen aufgeteilt.
Von der ABC-Abwehr mit ihren neuen Löschfahrzeugen, zu der Aufklärungsdrohne "Tracker",
bis zu den Vorführungen der Wasserfahrausbildung.
Die Besucher konnten sich hautnah ein Bild von den Gerätschaften,
aber auch den Fähigkeiten des Heeres machen.
Auch die Militärmusik Niederösterreich und die Trachtenkapelle Rossatz waren mit dabei
und sorgten für die Einleitung des Hauptaktes der Veranstaltung.
Anlass für das Aufgebot des Bundesheeres war die Angelobung von knapp 500 Rekruten.
Vier Wochen nach dem Einrücken und dem Abschluss der allgemeinen Basisausbildung,
gelobten die jungen Soldaten, der Republik Österreich und dem österreichischen Volke zu dienen.
"UND DEM ÖSTERREICHISCHEN VOLKE ZU DIENEN!"
Vor der beeindruckenden Kulisse des Stifts Dürnstein
sorgte die Militärmusik Niederösterreich
mit dem großen Zapfenstreich für den krönenden Abschluss.